Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie The Flash movie
was just released and the ending of the movie The
post-credits Scene set up a bunch of stuff a ton
of Easter eggs including James Gunn's big reboot
of DC movies so I know there's a ton of questions
about what's really going on so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're still
doing a giveaway for tickets to the movie and
there's a bunch of stuff in the movie that we
have to talk about so I have a bunch of bonus
videos planned this weekend my breakdown in
Easter eggs for the full movie will post tomorrow
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet because we'll be talking about everything
that happens at the end of the movie during
this video but the ending is very similar to the
character turns the flash goes through during the
ending of the original Flashpoint Story the
main flash realizes that he can't save this
alternate timeline he accidentally created which
is an amalgam of a bunch of different timelines
like Michael Keaton Batman's timeline Super Girls
timeline in this other alternate flashes timeline
all sort of mixed together like spaghetti in
a bowl is Michael Keaton's Batman joked about
earlier in the movie you wind up with a soup of
timelines all mixed together basically there was
also a line earlier in the movie about learning
to walk away from things like you need to learn
to walk away from certain situations and that's
basically what he comes to at the end of this
movie I just need to walk away we can't save this
Earth is destined to die no matter what we do and
the whole idea is that his younger self was 10
years younger hadn't learned that lesson yet
and just kept trying so became a savitar version
of himself like the dark flash they call him in
the movie which is his much older self he makes it
sound like he's been trying to change the timeline
like he's been doing this over and over again for
many many years like he says countless years so
he makes it sound like hundreds of years because
he is an old man like he has white hair his skin
is all wrinkled and he's covered in Kryptonian
pieces that appears his body you also remember
that the flash of speed force Powers also slow
down his aging process so he doesn't age like
a normal person does so him being this old means
that he's been trying this for hundreds of years
at least that's also why his speed Force lightning
has change to purple because he's learned to get
faster over time like he's basically more powerful
than the main version of The Flash that's why he
can't kill him he almost winds up dying during
all these realizations they have a bunch of
Multiverse cameos as the Multiverse itself starts
to collapse I have a lot of thoughts about the
way they visualize the Multiverse in this movie
and the cameos themselves I'll talk about that
in my full breakdown Easter eggs video because
it's like a whole separate thing I could make
a whole video just about the cameos themselves
it actually winds up being the younger alternate
version of himself that winds up taking care
of his older self like the savitar version the
dark flash version of them sacrificing himself
to save the main Flash and because dark flash
is basically the older version of that younger
Berry they both wind up canceling each other out
essentially so the whole idea is that the dark
flash dies at the end of this movie he's erased
from existence so technically he never existed
that means that in that particular timeline that
version of Barry winds up dying Zod takes over
that Earth Supergirl died Michael Keaton's Batman
died in that Universe just continues on in its
own timeline R.I.P to that version of Earth the
main flash travels back to his original timeline
trying to undo what he did Saving his mother so
ultimately she does wind up dying like he takes
the can of tomatoes out of his mother's shopping
cart the person that really killed her was an
unseen reverse flash in the movie Just Like
comic book Flashpoint they just allude to him
like you see the knife in her stomach that was
reverse flash I'll explain him during the movie
during my full breakdown in Easter eggs video
there was a reason why they didn't show him as a
big character in this movie there was already so
much stuff going on it would have been like a
four hour movie if they would included reverse
flash Barry says goodbye to her one last time and
if you couldn't tell like there's a brief second
where she actually recognizes the older berries
like oh my God it's my son she doesn't totally
get what's going on she just recognizes his face
like oh my God you're my berry somehow that's why
she offers him the awkward hug like uh here why
don't we just hug it out a little bit as he says
goodbye he makes another smaller change to the
Past by moving the can of tomatoes that his father
got to a higher shelf so the CCTV camera footage
will pick up his father's face exonerating him
in present day during his trial so he'll get out
of prison whereas before the can of tomatoes was
lower the camera didn't pick his face up so his
father stayed in prison once he gets back to his
apartment in present day where he left everything
seems exactly the same as it was as his apartment
as he rushes to the courthouse to watch his
father be exonerated hoping that it'll work
this time he passes by director Andy muschietti in
another Cameo scene stealing his hot dog then when
his father's exonerated when he goes to the
courthouse steps with Iris West he tells the
reporter it's basically a version of his story
about the spaghetti the timelines that Michael
Keaton Batman told him earlier basically telling
all the reporters in broad daylight exactly what
happened without getting into too much detail
like here's what I did changing the timelines
but using very vague spaghetti terms he gets
the date with Iris West finally it is Batman
calls him to come celebrate with him like Hey
this is wonderful his voice on the phone sounds
almost the exact same and as he pulls up in that
same custom Mercedes-Benz Maybach outsteps George
Clooney's Batman from Batman and Robin there
was a huge reaction in my theater the first two
times I watched this I saw at a couple different
screenings and both times people went crazy when
George Clooney's face showed up Barry winds up
dropping an F-bomb like who the hell is this guy
he says Batman out loud not quietly in Broad day
like there's reporters walking all around them
and he's like wait a minute you're not Batman in
George Clooney's Batman kind of leans in knowingly
like yes of course I'm not Batman smiling at
him like please stop telling everybody that
I'm Batman and there'll be some questions about
this too because Barry's tooth falls out again
so I know people will be like wait a minute does
that mean that he lost his powers again like he
lost him when he got stuck in that other alternate
timeline this time it's meant to be more of a joke
like he still has his powers because clearly he
talks about them during the actual post-credits
scene but the idea is that you can hurt the flash
badly enough that it wounds him and takes time for
him to heal his two is Fine Again by the events
of the post credit scene so the idea is that he
just experiences so much acute stress so quickly
like oh my god what have I done I've done it again
that his tooth falls out the credits themselves
start and during the main part of the credits
it's just meant to be a version of his save from
the beginning of the movie where he's rescuing
all the babies and the dog at the hospital in
the speed force in slow motion with the credits
playing while everything is falling in slow
motion the actual post-credits scene happens a
short while later like short time Jump with Barry
drinking at a bar with Jason momoa's Aquaman near
his apartment which is the same as his original
apartment like it's the same basic place where
he lives he says he can't get drunk because of
the way his powers work which is accurate they
had jokes about this during The Flash TV show
in the first couple of episodes and he's been
trying to explain everything that happened with
Flashpoint during the previous part of the movie
to Aquaman but he's gotten super drunk so he can
barely understand him he keeps mumbling to bury
about getting him more drinks like get some more
drinks and gives him one of his Atlantean Rings
which Barry says his atlante and treasure like
I can't give this to the bark key because it's
worth so much money it's Priceless confirming that
this alternate universe Aquaman like this Aquaman
from another timeline is just like the one from
the Justice League or like the original Aquaman
Barry says they're almost home and then he falls
face down in a puddle saying no no this is my home
because he's in water very very dirty puddle
water with an exasperated Berry just kind of
throwing his hands off like ah okay whatever
and even though things seem pretty chill in
this new amalgam time like this new spaghetti
timeline that he accidentally created with a
lesser version of Flashpoint just to be clear
they're not saying that Jason momoa's Aquaman
always became Aquaman on George Clooney Batman's
Earth is a situation like happened previously in
the movie where a bunch of different people's
timelines all start overlapping together in the
idea in this new timeline soup that he created
this new alternate universe alternate timeline
things aren't quite as chaotic yet I know there'll
be tons of questions about what this means about
the future of The Flash and what's happening with
these characters is he gonna try and change things
again even though it seems like it's just meant to
be a funny bookend to everything the idea is that
for the foreseeable future this main flash here
is going to stay in this new alternate timeline
he created by Saving his father and just learn to
accept all the minor changes like I guess I just
have to live with this weird alternate version
of Batman okay whatever because it does seem like
he's still friends with this Earth's version of
the Justice League but just to be clear he's not
going to go back and undo his father's exoneration
just to get back to that original Justice League
Earth that he left from at the beginning of
the movie so he still has his powers but he's
basically stuck of his own accord he chooses
to stay in this new reality there'll be a lot
of talk about this too because originally there
was a very different ending with a very different
post-credits scene involving Henry Cavill Superman
Flash getting warnings while he was in the speed
force about a coming crisis on infinite Earths
across the Multiverse that was what a lot of
those Cameo scenes earlier in the movie with the
collapsing Multiverse was meant to set up I'll
talk about that alternate ending all those deleted
scenes and some of my bonus videos this weekend
because the movie started out being like four
hours long and they're originally way more cameos
way more Justice League stuff way more Multiverse
stuff sending out future movies like Man of Steel
2 with Henry Cavill Superman Wonder Woman three
and all that changed at the last minute after
James Gunn was hired last year and decided to
reboot DC movies so they had to make a bunch of
edits so in the version of the movie that you'll
all see in theaters they wanted this Flash movie
to end in a way that would explain how you never
see the Ezra Miller flash again if they decide to
recast and not bring him back in the future James
gunnon the director of the movie have said a lot
about that so I'll explain that later this weekend
in my bonus videos there's a billion Easter eggs
and references during the movie and even with
the cuts there's still a ton of Cameo scenes
my full Easter eggs and breakdown video will post
on Friday be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that I'll try to finish all the
bonus videos for the movie as quickly as possible
there's so much to talk about I don't think it'll
be quite as long as my video for Spider-Man across
the spiderverse that was almost like a full
hour long everyone click here for that full
breakdown video I'll update the link as soon as
I post that and click here for all my other Flash
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!